hello everyone and welcome to the second
match of the FED World Cup semi-finals
between n abasov and Magnus Carlson
you've seen what happened in the
previous round Magnus has defeated ninja
and now ninja needs to uh to win with
white pieces to force tie breaks and
it's not going to be easy Magnus is
having a very very good tournament but
so is uh so is n abasov now let's see
who goes into the finals uh will we have
tie breaks and who will face the winner
of the match Carana pran and let's check
it out n has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to D4 and here you are
already being treated to something very
special knight to F6 Knight to F3 D5 and
Bishop to F4 uh like against vid ninja
goes for the London system against
Magnus Carlson and we've seen Magnus
play the London we've seen Magnus play
against the London and well it's always
a privilege seeing how the the the best
player in the world will face against
this uh notorious opening and here we
have Bishop to F5 going for the
symmetrical variation inter
interestingly Magnus has faced the
symmetrical London setup with both white
and black he haded with black against
Leon Aran for example that game ended in
a draw he haded with white against
Wesley so who he defeated and he also
haded with white against Anish giri also
the game ended in a draw so he knows his
way around this setup we have E3 E6
Knight B to D2 and Knight B to D7 so
continuing in this hypers symmetrical uh
variation we have C4 and now although
there is one game in the database where
C5 was played keeping the Symmetry
Magnus goes de captures on C4 so he
breaks symmetry we have Bishop captures
on C4 and now Bishop to E7 is a known
move but here we have Bishop to D6 by
Magnus and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
uh so Knight to E5 and this is a move
you will always face whenever white
plays some sort of a queen's Pawn
opening this Knight the E5 move will
always happen and of course everyone
with the black pieces hates the move uh
because it just requires you to
calculate all that much even if your
Magnus cars and Magnus really took his
time here and he spent some 15 minutes
on his next move until he decided uh
well okay there are basically some some
candidates moves you consider you could
capture on E5 giving up the bishop you
could Castle right away or you could put
your own Knight to E4 uh much like white
put his own Knight on E5 and now let's
say let's say you play Bishop captures
on E5 D captures on E5 Knight to D5
attacking the bishop let's say Bishop
goes to G3 and Knight to C5 it's a very
uh a very possible way to play also you
gain a very nice control over the D3
Square for example white can castle and
now you're going to Castle as well black
is perfectly fine here but Magnus thinks
he can do even better than this he plays
Knight to E4 and okay now we have a
trade uh we have Pawn to F3 Knight
captures and D2 Queen captures and pawn
to F6 this this is basically why Magnus
spent uh 15 to 20 minutes calculating
this and whenever your opponent will
play the Knight on E5 you will also have
to do this because it's uh if you can
play F6 kick away the Knight and be okay
then you've solved all of your opening
issues and if not you're just going to
blunder the game so Knight captures on
D7 Queen captures and pawn to E4 now
chases away the bishop we have Bishop to
G6 and Rook to D1 uh we have Bishop
captures on F4 Magnus going for further
trades uh Queen captures and now Bishop
to F7 remember Magnus only needs a draw
uh to qualify for the finals of the
fiday World Cup whereas abasov needs to
win this in order to force ey breaks
with King to F2 very nice move by abasov
the king will be extremely safe here the
pawns are keeping him safe and The Rook
can now come into the game we have Queen
to C6 putting pressure on the bishop
Bishop to B3 and queen to B6 now
aligning the queen nicely with the King
also getting ready to castle with tempo
as this will put more pressure on the D4
pawn and if the bishop moves you are
also putting pressure on B2 so the queen
is uh most certainly excellently placed
on B6 we have Queen to E3 and now Queens
side castles of course the D4 Pawn is
already nicely defended so you don't
need to worry but you should start
doubling up on the D file Magnus will do
the same Rook to D7 we have Rook H to D1
and of course Rook H to d8 and now
Bishop back to C4 uh we have Pawn to C5
by Magnus not worried about moving Pawns
in front of his King as it does put
pressure on the D pawn and this forces
the pawn to be Advanced further so Pawn
to D5 we have e captures on D5 and now
while you could trade Bishops here
abasov wants as as much material on the
board as possible he really doesn't want
this to fizzle out into an early draw e
captures on D5 and now King to B8 so
here when you're when you're playing in
such a tournament uh where you are for
example facing Magnus Carlson uh and
you're down by a full point it's weird
but because usually when You Face Magnus
Carlson you don't mind the draw but here
it just I mean although you don't mind a
draw against Magnus Carson you really
need to beat him if you want to advance
and situation on the clock here okay
pretty similar abasov had a little less
than 40 minutes on the clock some 39
minutes and Magnus had 30 minutes we
have Pawn to A3 IO wants to strike with
Pawn to B4 because how else do you get
um a hold of the black king and queen to
D6 now uh we have Pawn to G3 as Queen
captur on H2 was the threat and now Rook
to E7 Magnus grabs the open eile for his
Rook we have Queen back to C3 and now H5
preparing Pawn to H4 uh or maybe even
Pawn to H3 but probably H4 and capturing
on G3 we have Pawn to B4 abaso finally
plays it it's time to go after the black
king and now Magnus could go for
something like Rook to C7 to align The
Rook with the White Queen but he goes
for Pawn to H4 just going after abas
of's King we have B captures on C5 Queen
captures on C5 with check Queen to D4
blocking and Magnus plays H captures on
G3 this comes with check H captures and
queen captures and D4 SO trading over
the Queens Rook captures and Rook to C7
and this is the position equal material
uh Bishops of the same color and two
pairs of Rooks each uh which means um
it's probably a draw and unless you
manage to really squeeze something out
abaso 35 minutes on the clock Magnus 27
minutes on the clock but this game is
going to a very very special place as
you'll see we have Pawn to G4 uh Rook to
C5 we have Pawn to A4 and now Bishop to
E8 now Magnus no longer needs to attack
this Pawn as this Pawn is now presented
as a Target we have Bishop to B3
defending it and Rook to C3 and now the
Rook here is um quite powerful so of
course abasov has to trade a pair of
Rooks to get rid of it we have Rook
captures Rook captures and now uh once
one a pair of Rooks has been traded off
it's safe to bring the king into the
game King C7 Rook to E3 and now Bishop
to G6 of course you cannot move the Rook
from the E5 with that Bishop on E8 so
Bishop to G6 and now on to G5 creating
some weaknesses here trying to double up
the the G Pawn we have Rook to E8
offering a rook trade and here we have G
captures G captures Rook captures an E8
Bishop captures and now King to E3 so we
have this end game with the Bishops of
the same color but it is only abasov
with the pass Pawn he has the pass D
pawn and he of course will try to push
it all the way to Victory if Magnus gets
a free move in he can also create a pass
B Pawn on on the queen side so Pawn to
A5 sorry Pawn to A5 locking that pawn on
the light Square so the the uh Whit's
Bishop on B3 is stuck there defending it
and now King to D4 we have King to D6
and now Pawn to F4 is there a way for
abasov to create some threats here uh
let's see with Bishop to H5 by Magnus
and now King to E4 uh sorry King to E4
we have Bishop to G4 and now Bishop back
to C2 we have King to C5 and Bishop back
to B3 uh we have Bishop to H3 and now
Bishop back to C2 we have Bishop to D7
and now Bishop to D1 so doesn't seem
like there's all that much to do here uh
King to C4 and now Bishop to E2 with
check we have King to C5 and Bishop back
to D1 uh we have Pawn to B6 by Magnus
and now comes Bishop to C2 uh 9 minutes
for abasov 15 minutes for Magnus and
okay time control has been reached so uh
it's uh it means they've again spent
quite a lot of time getting to this
position we have King to C4 Bishop to D3
with check King to B4 going after the
pawn and Bishop to C2 Magnus just
repeats King to C3 Bishop to D1 and now
King to C4 we have Bishop E2 check King
to B4 and now Bishop to D1 King to C3
and here abasov plays it pawn to D6 and
now uh the problem is if you play a
particular move you are dead lost here
not just a particular move there is only
one move that doesn't lose the game for
Magnus and it's incredible uh how how
how easy it is to to miss this move move
so uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only move that doesn't
lose the game for Magnus while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
thinking about the B4 square and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh it is not King to B4 it is King
to C4 but you would only come to re this
realization if you first thought about
King to B 4 and calculated that it loses
the game now King B4 looks very natural
because the bishop is stuck here
guarding the A4 Pawn uh the problem is
it's not look at this beautiful move
Bishop G4 and now uh Magnus would be
completely lost you cannot trade Bishops
because then F5 and the bishop can no
longer control the D7 Square you're just
going to promote this Pawn to a queen
and of course if Bishop to C6 check then
you're just going to play King F5 and if
King to C5 you will just play King to E6
uh controlling everything here Bishop
captures on A4 but now King to E7 and
after Bishop to C6 you will advance the
pawn bishop captures and this is now
completely winning um for while Bishop
captures on D7 okay you can start
pushing those Queens side pawns but it
doesn't matter F5 you're going to play
Pawn to A4 King captures uh paon to A3
and now you're just going to stop the
pawn and that's it there's no more way
to do this you're just going to move the
king and queen this Pawn white is much
much faster here so after D6 Magnus
first thought about King to B four as
one always should he rejected it because
it loses and then he played King to C4
which of course you guys also found
after deciding King to B4 doesn't work
uh and now uh he does not lose the game
but again you have to be very very very
precise abasov plays Bishop to G4 the
absolute best move and again you cannot
trade if you trade F5 and uh Magnus is
lost here but Magnus finds the only move
Bishop to C6 with check and now it's a
bit different because now if you go King
to F5 the king is already on C4 it's not
on B4 so you can go King to D5 and stop
the white king from infiltrating and now
it's a draw King captures on F6 King
captures on D6 that's all there is to it
so after Bishop to C6 check King to E3
was played but now Magnus captures on A4
okay he will have to give up the bishop
but now H the white king is much much
further away and he will not be able to
uh get rid of the the the F6 Pawn which
is on a dark Square in time to to
advance the past F Pawn so D7 Bishop
captures Bishop captures and Now Pawn to
B5 and okay now the position is equal
but still you have to play this out
perfectly and abaso really went into a
deep think here he had to see if there
was anything more to play for and he
played King to D2 uh we have Pawn to B4
by Magnus we have Bishop to E6 with
check King to D4 now we have Pawn to F5
uh and of course Pawn to A4 we have King
to C2 and now King to E4 uh Bishop to D7
goes after the A4 Pawn King to E5 now of
course if you H capture then King
captures on F5 so King to D3 and now
Pawn to A3 with have King to C2 Pawn to
A2 King to B2 and pawn to B3 of course
you cannot take magnus's Pawn here
because then A1 becomes a queen uh so
here Bishop to E6 was played and now we
have King to E4 and now Magnus said I
just don't care anymore whatever you
play I'm just going to move my king to
E5 and E4 and that's it it's going to be
a draw you know by by both of us having
nothing to do so I was of AG greeding he
played Bishop captures on B3 and now
everything gets traded off A1 Queen this
comes with check King captures on A1
King captures on F5 and now Bishop to C2
check we have King to E5 King to B1 and
now Pawn to F5 abasov captured on F5 and
here it was in this position on move 74
that n abaso and Magnus Carlson agreed
to a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here it is basically a draw by
insufficient material you know okay it
be it' be okay if Magnus captured he but
still it's it's a draw by insuff
official material which means that as
Magnus won the first game and the second
game ended in a draw Magnus Carlson is
the first uh finalist of the FED World
Cup
2023 and he will wait for the winner of
the match pranda versus Fabiano karwana
uh this is the first time Magnus ever
reached the the finals of the F World
Cup he was knocked out to Young shishto
Duda in the semi-finals of 2021 now he
reaches the finals can he take it all
the way and win the only tournament he
never won at the Fay World Cup we'll
have to wait and see uh will it be
Prague will it be Fabby uh whoever
whoever it is well since okay I mean I I
want both of them to win of course best
luck to to everyone who already came
this far but he already faced Fabby in
so many uh great top tier competitions
he even played a world chair
championship match against Fabby uh you
know maybe it'd be it'd be it'd be more
more uh of a of a not not a challenge
but something for for Prague to Aspire
to you know if if he qualifies for the
finals but I would be I'm I I would be
thrilled whoever qualifies so you know
really happy to enjoy that with you guys
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it we'll see how the other
games um finished or maybe they're
they're already over I can just check
quickly if you guys are interested in
the answer uh yes okay so it has ended I
will mention it now so for those of you
who are not interested in the result of
the Prague Fabby game do not listen to
what I'm about to say uh it has ended in
a draw which means tomorrow we will have
tie breaks between Fabiana corana and
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank k o Thomas Hoy
Wives and Lovers Andes and Robert Blum
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the feed World Cup until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day